[Music]
hey everybody it's charlie a whole bunch
of websites are now reporting on this
avengers trailer that was posted to
reddit so i'll do a breakdown of that
but after i do i'll talk about what
parts i think are more plausible than
others
because the way it describes some of the
teams is relatively plausible and the
way it describes where some of the
characters show up
seem to corroborate what we've seen in
behind the scenes photos so some of it
sounds a little more outlandish than
other parts there's a new round of that
spider-man ps4 game giveaway too all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video i'll name a new winner at the end
of this
so it says the trailer starts off
showing a damaged infinity gauntlet in a
field on thanos farm from the end of
infinity war that planet where he ended
the movie
the camera pushes in on the damaged
gauntlet and you hear tony stark's
voiceover
we were destined to lose then they start
the big epic music score
a quinjet lands in wakanda which is
described as looking kind of like a
wasteland since the end of infinity war
captain america says we've come so far
tony and nebula step
off the quinjet is the remaining
avengers approach steve has a look of
relief and says
tony nods as if they've kind of made up
a little bit iron man is still
emotionally broken after the events of
infinity war but he manages a smirk
becca cap to acknowledge him the marvel
logo flashes and you get a glimpse of
the battle of new york from the original
avengers movie you see the older version
of loki from the events of that movie
on top of tony stark's tower looking
really surprised in a moment where he
was not originally surprised during that
movie
there's a flash of blue light they cut
to black then you see the wakandan
throne room
after the events of infinity war in the
future mbaku is now king
not shuri black panther she hasn't
ascended to the throne
he's got a brand new kingsguard that's a
mixture of his hill tribe with the dora
milaje so it looks a little bit
different like they've combined their
cultures together
sheree and banner are in shuri's lab
working on a new project which is
probably the reason why she hasn't
ascended to the throne then in that same
future timeline they cut to hawkeye's
farm you see black widow there in full
battle gear and i think that's just to
show that everybody's all broken up they
haven't completely come back together
yet
you see black widow looking at a map
with a bunch of locations and pins on it
you see a really quick shot of thanos
with that sword that we've seen in
concept art walking down an alleyway in
new york city
they don't say whether it's happening in
present day or in the past during the
battle of new york
they cut to a different scene of hawkeye
in full ronin gear with glowing eyes
aiming a bow and arrow before he shoots
at the camera
you cut to a couple different shots of
the quantum realm then they cut to a
different shot of scott lang
just in regular civilian clothing
running through a park dodging
explosions
then they cut to a scene in outer space
with thorin valkyrie on board a cruise
ship
thor says if the stories are true you're
our universe's last hope
they don't say who he's talking to but i
think the idea is that he's talking to
captain marvel
then they cut to a scene of an older
version of iron man walking through the
hallways
in the avengers facility which is also
doubling as a new shield base
holding a special orange briefcase think
pulp fiction briefcase like what's in
the briefcase something really special
but also there have been some behind the
scenes pictures with him in shield gear
so it also implies that he reformed
shields since what happened during
winter soldier because thus far it
hasn't really existed in the mcu for a
while
there's a shot of banner not hulk
wearing the spandex suit that we've seen
him in the concept art running from
something looking terrified he hasn't
changed into the hulk but in all the
concept art he
is the hulk in that spandex suit they
cut to a shot of ant-man appearing out
of a flash of light in this really
desolate place
there's a shot from his first person
perspective not sure where he is
freaking out then the camera focuses on
vormir where the soul stone was during
infinity war
in the description isn't really specific
about where
it looks like he is if he actually does
land on vormir or if he lands somewhere
else
then they just include a shot of vormir
and it looks kind of misleading
then you come back to a scene of rocking
a nebula modifying some new weapons in a
lab
rocket says when can we try this bad boy
out they smile at each other and fist
bump
it seems weird that nebula would fist
bump someone
karen gillen said that she made a
special new friend during avengers 4
maybe that special new friend winds up
being rocket but we get our first
glimpse of iron man
in the red gold nanotech armor the
classic armor that we saw concept art of
a little while ago i've already done a
video about that
hulk falls from the sky lands in front
of him and it seems like they're on a
battlefield
because it cuts to a shot of thanos in
full armor smiling
hulk smiles back as if it's time for
their rematch then they cut to a
different shot
back in japan war machine black widow
in captain america in full avengers gear
are surrounded by the yakuza
hawkeye in his ronin gear making it seem
like he's working with the yakuza not
against them
they cut back to a shot in the sanctum
with wong communicating with dr
strange's soul via some sort of portal
either he's inside the soul gem which is
actually something from the infinity
gauntlet comic book
if that actually does turn out to be
true i'll talk a little bit more about
it they cut to a scene in the future of
an
older gray-haired tony stark and ant-man
in a post-apocalyptic new york city
wasteland
the screen flashes back and forth
multiple times through different scenes
we see captain marvel floating with her
fists all lit up with energy like we saw
during her trailer a little while ago
her eyes are lit up there's a shot of
thanos
inside the soul world of the soul gem
with that young version of gamora
screaming at him
then there's a shot of loki in thor back
during the battle of new york fighting
the
towery together then there's a shot of
iron man handing captain america the new
version of his prototype shield that he
was making during homecoming but they're
inside the wakandan throne room
get that man a shield then they cut back
to a different shot of iron man and
ant-man
ant-man walks up to him while he's
holding this orange briefcase
iron man is confused and says how is
this even possible
then you see the two of them traveling
through the quantum realm
they arrive back during the battle of
new york during 2012
then supposedly the last shot before the
big title reveal is a close-up of thanos
damaged gauntlet the melted one
with one of the gems disappearing it
doesn't say which gem but it's implied
because they're back during the battle
of new york that'll probably
be the space stone but we'll talk about
that in a second because
the title reveal says that the title is
avengers annihilation
so i know there's all kinds of rumors
about what the title is take that with a
grain of salt i will talk about the
stuff from this that i think is the most
plausible and stuff that i think is
bullcrap
but then supposedly there's a stinger at
the end of the trailer
where it's hulk training in that new
shield slash
avengers base with black widow in
captain america
the description reads the captain
america is noticing
hulk's been training non-stop like
hardcore like what's going on he asked
him why are you training so hard
and while he's in hulk form he speaks
with banner's voice saying my rematch is
coming real soon
i can feel it that seems like it's
designed to be their spider-man captain
america shield oh my god moment like oh
my god it's the hulk and he's talking
like banner
does that mean he's gonna be crazy
powerful in this movie because there was
the other part of the description that
read that he's in that special unitard
getting ready to fight thanos on a
battlefield
there have been a couple of behind the
scenes shots that corroborate
some parts of this description but you
really do have to take it with a grain
of salt because it implies some heavy
time travel in avengers
stealing infinity stones from different
parts of the timeline
the stuff about iron man being in charge
of a slightly new version of shield
seems a little bit more legit because
we've seen him walking around
in shield gear the part about them
featuring the older version of loki from
the battle of new york
sounds legit because we've seen pictures
of him on set in that original uniform
all the stuff with black widow with
ronin hawkeye seem to jive with what
we've heard about scenes that they've
been filming
the scenes with thor meeting up with
captain marvel trying to get her help
seem to jive with what we've heard about
that
really like the biggest thing in here
though the biggest question mark
is the question of time travel like i
could believe that umbaku would ascend
the throne because shuri wants to spend
all of her time
researching something quote unquote
special that will help them fix things
with banner
but again giant grain of salt for all
this especially for the title
sometimes the reason why you see
descriptions like these early on and
only parts of them wind up being true
is is because of the way marvel makes
their trailers what will happen is
that marvel and other studios will
subcontract to trailer houses which are
like special groups of people that do
nothing but edit trailers for big
hollywood studios but in order to make
those trailers the studio like marvel
has to give them
some footage from the movie so the
trailer houses are cutting these
trailers
way before the russos have ever finished
the movie so the trailer that the
trailer house
makes even if marvel likes it and wants
to release it might not reflect the
actual plot of the movie when everything
is said and done
but let me know in the comments what do
you think about this idea of them
traveling through the quantum realm
going back in time literally
and stealing infinity stones that was a
rumor early on we'll see if it pans out
but what'll happen is i got a couple
more videos coming today new daredevil
there'll be some new spider-man posting
soon so just check that top pin comment
for my video schedule
congratulations noah cool you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel
so i can get your details click here to
watch chris evans talk about the plot of
avengers 4
and click here to learn all about
spider-man during phase 4 and the
venomverse spin-off movies
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]